make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and on today's episode of our beyond
omega level series we are going to talk
about a character
that i've seen requested in the comments
more than a few times
quantum superman but as we get into a
discussion of this character
it's going to become obvious that
quantum superman is not technically a
version of superman
as his name suggests as he's not a
version of clark kent but rather
the earth 4 version of alan adam who's
better known by a superhero moniker
captain adam now i have a video in this
series on captain adam if you're
unfamiliar with a character and want to
know more about his origin and powers
so i'm not going to get too into the
main version of the character here but
instead we're just going to focus on the
earth 4 version so
this character was created by grant
morrison and first appeared in final
crisis superman beyond number one
in 2008. now this was a tie-in series
that sees one of the multiverses 52
monitors
zlovala recruit different superman from
across the multiverse to battle the
returning mandrak
the dark monitor now one of those
supermen is the allen adam of earth 4
who's described as
hailing from a condensed universe where
the laws of physics are different now we
learn a little bit about his origin
in final crisis secret files where we
literally get a blurb of information
about him including that he was an air
force captain
whose body disintegrated when an
experimental engine depowered by a
volatile element known as u-235
exploded the particles of the u-235
fused with the particles that made up
adam's body and he remakes himself into
a new enhanced version of his prior self
which glows blue
due to the radiation which of course
sounds nothing like dr manhattan
of course not but basically quantum
superman is grant morrison's adaptation
of dr manhattan which is an interesting
concept considering that dr manhattan
was actually inspired
by captain adam but we also learned from
the little bit of information that we're
given that quantum superman is one of
the most powerful beings
in the entire multiverse and because of
this immense power
he's scared of what he has become and
takes drugs to curb his quantum senses
which is a form of near omniscience that
grants him knowledge unbound by time
or space now being under the influence
of these power dampening drugs
makes it possible for adam to be largely
controlled by his bosses in the military
which would not be possible
if you are tapping into quantum senses
quantum superman the only superpowered
being on his earth
goes on to join a team known as pax
americana designed to maintain peace and
order in the united states
along with peacemaker blue beetle the
question and nightshade and so this is
basically the watchmen if the original
plan
of using charlton characters instead of
original characters had actually come to
fruition and so moving on to his powers
quantum superman is virtually omniscient
and omnipotent he's remarked that he
observes the three-dimensional world
in much the same way that we observe the
two-dimensional worlds of comic books he
was also able to interface
with the ultimate thule's computer a
piece of monitor technology
and was able to process 100 yota bytes
of
information in seconds i have no idea
what unibytes are but it sounds like a
lot adam is also able to create multiple
copies of himself
much in the same way that dr manhattan
was able to do so and he can also alter
the size of himself
as well as his copies his most
impressive power however is his ability
to alter reality which he claims to be
able to do in eight dimensions
and while we don't see many examples of
this due to the limited number of
appearances quantum superman has made
the fact that he is an advanced reality
warper places him
well beyond omega level now the most
impressive feats that we do see quantum
superman pull off
occurs during the final crisis superman
beyond miniseries when he fuses the
personalities of superman and ultraman
the evil version of superman from earth
3
a feat that required an immense amount
of energy with the essences of those two
superman fused they power the cosmic
armor or thought robot which i've had a
beyond omega level video on before but
is basically a robot that was built by
the monitors to protect the multiverse
from mandrak the ultimate evil but the
robot is fueled by the combined powers
of superman and ultraman
and runs on the concepts of duality
symmetry probabilities
possibilities and memories the cosmic
armor is said to exist in four
dimensions meaning that it is untethered
by the laws of the three-dimensional
multiverse and is widely considered to
be the most powerful version of superman
to ever
exist and none of it would have ever
been possible without quantum superman
being able to channel enough energy to
combine the two opposing essences of
superman and ultraman now being as
powerful as quantum superman is
does come with some drawbacks i
mentioned earlier that alan adam prefers
to remain under the influence of power
dampening drugs instead of face the
reality of how powerful he is but
another side effect of his abilities is
that he has lost touch with his emotions
even to the point that he no longer
feels attraction for his dog he even
goes so far as to disassemble a dog
telekinetically in a very disturbing
scene
trying to find some reason within the
dog to feel an emotional attachment to
it
that's messed up once he realizes that
he's destroyed his beloved pet he does
begin to cry so it seems that he can
feel emotion to some degree but the fact
remains
that being one of the most powerful
entities in the multiverse takes an
extremely high emotional toll on him
and yeah that's pretty much everything
to know about quantum superman right
he's extremely powerful
but rarely used in dc comics really only
showing up when grant morrison's writing
stories about the multiverse so if we're
going to have a series on the most
powerful characters
in comics the quantum superman of earth
4 definitely makes the list but let me
know what you guys think let me know
down in the comments section
if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Applause]
[Music]
you